[Music]
so as inflation surges gas prices
heating and cooling of your home prices
surge
everything you buy at every store you go
to is going through the roof the
supplies change struggles continue to
all drag down the economy what is the
democratic socialist party's answer oh
let's spend trillions more on their
reckless far left you know socialist
marxist utopia agenda and mortgage you
and your children's future to try and
turn their far left fantasies into a
reality because remember democrats have
continued to lie about what this build
back better bolshevik plan really costs
for example oh penn's wharton school
actually estimates hardly members of the
right wing conspiracy the plan cost
closer to 4.5 trillion
not what they're telling you 1.7 and the
well-respected committee for a
responsible federal budget says the plan
could actually cost upwards of 4.8
trillion now why the disparity you might
ask yourself well it's because of the
well let's say creative math the
democrats are feeding you it's based on
a number of arbitrary so-called sunset
provisions that in reality will all be
extended every one of them far past
their current proposed expiration dates
let me translate it's an accounting
trick leftist socialist used to lie to
you here to react to all of tonight's
big breaking news senator lindsey graham
my understand is that your chamber the
senate just passed a continuing
resolution on the debt ceiling did any
republican cave this time
no this wasn't the debt ceiling this was
just keep the government funded to
february 18th we haven't addressed the
debt ceiling yet and i will predict that
not one republican will vote to raise
the debt ceiling the democratic party
senators i don't mean to interrupt you
spending by themselves but the
republican party said they wouldn't do
it in september
up till the last two days and then mitch
and and 10 other republicans caved like
a cheap suit yeah
yeah i don't think it's gonna happen
again for a lot of reasons and uh keep
this tape and see if i'm wrong but uh
yeah so tonight was about funding the
government but you're the only guy in
the whole town talking about the fraud
that's the bill back better bill this is
a complete fraud this bill doesn't cost
1.6 trillion over 10 years it costs 4.7
or 4.8 trillion depending on who you
believe
penn wharton or the bipartisan budget
group it doesn't add 367 billion to the
debt over 10 years it adds 2.7 trillion
how can that be the programs in this
bill
are being are budget gimmicks we expand
child tax credits we pay for free
pre-k and community college but under
the bill these programs go away after
two years i will be in the mba before
these programs go away these programs
are never going away and when you look
at these programs for a 10-year period
the cost of the bill over doubles and
the effect on the deficit is almost
tenfold and i hope joe manchin who's
been talking about budget gimmicks
will respond appropriately next friday
i've been told by the congressional
budget office i'm the ranking republican
on the budget committee they will
analyze this bill assuming that the new
programs do not sunset which is reality
they will give me a cost estimate if the
programs stay in effect which they will
and it's going to blow the doors off of
washington and if we pass this bill god
help america okay now joe manchin from
west virginia has been saying hey wait a
minute i want to see the numbers here
now we've got
numbers from wharton penn
and we have numbers from the committee
for responsible federal budget they say
4.8 trillion dollars not 1.7 wharton is
saying nearly 4.5 trillion uh how is it
those numbers can be so far off and you
are the the ranking member of the budget
committee my understanding is you're
insisting the cbo the quote gold
standard as the democrats say
supposedly nonpartisan that they will
score this bill
using
you know removing any of these
ridiculous presumption of a sunset
provision
well sean you're a smart guy you got a
smart audience how many people believe
listening to me tonight that once the
federal government starts paying for
pre-kindergarten and community college
that will stop paying two years from now
ronald reagan said the closest thing to
immortality on earth is a government
program this is a budget gimmick no
democrat wants these programs to end
they put a sunset on them to lower the
cost to hoodwink the american public joe
manchin has been concerned about these
budget gimmicks so joe
i'm going to get the cbo the gold
standard to score the bill without
budget gimmicks and here's what i think
is going to show
two to two and a half times the cost
over four and a half trillion dollars in
cost not 1.7 in terms of the deficit
which you care about and i care about
it's not 367 billion over 10 years it's
going to be 2.7 to 2.8 trillion over 10
years this bill is a complete fraud and
i intend to expose it next friday a week
from a week from tomorrow and hopefully
the cbo will live up to the commitment
they made to me to score the bill
without budget gimmicks
all right so what are the odds i mean i
assume i think you're friends with joe
manchin if i'm not mistaken um i've
gotten along with him over the years i
don't agree with him on everything but
we certainly agree on energy uh energy
is pivotal to his state of west virginia
i know he doesn't like biden's energy
policies
but he also is conservative in the sense
that he sees the danger of the debt and
the deficit here
yes
so here's what i think joe manchin is a
good guy he's a democrat but he's a west
virginia democrat he has said that he's
concerned about inflation if this bill
becomes law bill back better it will
destroy energy production in this
country because the green new deal
components of this bill make it harder
to produce oil and gas the 17 programs
that are sunsetted actually never go
away and if you're worried about
inflation the last thing you want to do
is add 2.7 trillion dollars to the
federal deficit and spend four and a
half to four point seven trillion
dollars on new government which will
uh pour gasoline on inflation so joe has
said he's worried about budget gimmicks
and here's what i hope to be able to
prove a week from tomorrow that this
bill is full of budget gimmicks and when
you take out the budget gimmicks the
true cost of this bill is
way over what they say it is that the
entire concept to build back better is a
fraud with the budget gimmicks and i'm
going to expose the fraud
all right senator lindsey graham south
carolina we're going to be watching
closely republicans any republican that
helps these democrats they've kept you
out of the entire budgetary process they
have the house the senate and they got
the white house
don't help them ruin the country any
more than they are hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else